hawaï ainsi que tu sais pas c'est nom de
l'invité mystère mystère des français
[Musique]
c'est moi qui ai pensé mais d'accord
qu'est ce qu'un corps son père ou sa
mère nancy 75 cents c'est quoi ton papa
ils foutent et état il disait ça n'est
pas décollé il dit ensuite en genre je
voudrais toujours 43 ans disent y est
que la france quand et demi en sentant
l'année faut il arrêter les publics
sensibles
ces processeurs ils sont républicains
aussi d'un grain ou légale nous donner
envie je fais l'armée n'a pas voulu
pourquoi je fais j'ai visé trop haut et
vinci 11e maieddine 3 et rachitique
parce que cela quand ces oeuvres oiseaux
loi de sa série ouais parce que la ligue
1 3-1 à des parents stationnés sur une
taille surnommé papa souvent corps comme
et
roubaix est
donc la validation que j'arrive à
l'humain maritime mais chaleureuse et
aux techniques au coeur est ailleurs que
ce soit pas être deuxième à j'imagine
pas chic
tu fais quoi comme sport
marchât biens appartements ouais c'est
profitable à savoir combien par jour
avec tout le temps faim les aimer et
développe les idées plus arrêter combien
de fois définitivement de fumer du chéné
s'appelle plus au pmc rejetant tu veux
dire j'ai changé de club étoile est
question mais elle est brûlée et blu
cela l a jamais tous deux battus et plus
en veine mentale et devoir s'arrêter
quand même pas de cellule d'urgence est
en fait que c'est une pure calomnie et
jonah hill s'est jamais arrêté de vrai à
l'époque où tout robuste avec quoi pas
le ventre
et quand j'ai commencé c'était
j'avais 11 ans ouais c'est pas moi qui
ne le regarde papa maman je suis
mauvaise nouvelle était petit
voilà est venu gagner à massy tout
arrêté pendant plus de deux semaines
pour leurs forces et hp est amer valor y
maintenant c'est la paix à françois
lequoy l'autre et bien tous les deux
arrivés à l'angoissé un enfin bref j'ai
vu avant j'attends maintenant ça va bien
ça c'est l'opium du peuple à goûter à la
ferme est faible oui j'étais à fond de
faire s'il n'ya pas voilà oui ces achats
s'est drôlement vrai parce que j'aurais
examiné patrice appel gonzesse qui bien
placé à l'échauffement mais l'iran n'a
pas cédé aux politiques alors tu es plus
sociale démocrate ou libérale de progrès
wicked vos liens afin qu'ils pouvaient
par l'équipe était quelqu'un enfin bref
pour exister pouvoir correspondre un
pays de droit où n'importe qui c'est
plutôt royalistes comme mec à ma chère
oui enfin plus tôt ces mêmes sites au
lieu jeudi en ce sens là
c'est parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
perdu le goût en 80 [ __ ] n'est ce pas
mr des choses mais quel pouvoir
la loi pas de miracle pour les fusionner
avant il faudra les qualités donc au
poète génial
nathan lane ils ont dû alors théâtre
cinéma littérature chanson tu as fait
quoi de tout appareil tout cas tout fait
la jrgn libye
les gars j'ai pigé compétentes et rend
le personnage s'intéresse déjà que les
gens possible et à l'intelligence et
musulmans mais est ce que tu fais de
mieux tout ça c'est quoi que j'ai vu de
tout ça instinctivement spontanément et
ça j'ai l'habitude du vainqueur mal
quand tu ne gagnes pas conclure j'ai dit
josiane et à l'aide d'un lourd pour les
trials salut succès que les femmes et
par oui j'ai des filles à abandonner
juste quelqu'un dernière copine fait
partie et coûteux des enfants ça il en
faut rien jamais
à lire mais j'en ai bien fait combien il
ya sujet j'aimerais un scout est le seul
à savoir pas mal et tu leur racontera
quand ils seront grands ce que tu
faisais quand était grand en trois ans
pourquoi et si c'était à refaire je
referais exactement la même chose
ces trois ans philippe léotard est ce
que tu as entendu parler des questions
tordues beaucoup de questions tombé j'ai
envie de leur parler angers
[Musique]
ces prêts est arrivé début janvier
questions j'imagine que tu parles dans
un vaisseau spatial à mon avis la télé
ce soir tu es bon là tu pars dans un
vaisseau spatial sur mars 4 en juillet
ouais 92 seul tu as le choix d'une pp
qui tu choisis dorothée ou chantal goya
qui j'ai dorothée alors toujours le
vaisseau spatial ouais là il y avait là
il ya plus de pépé qu'est ce tu préfères
un mec ou la main gauche
la main gauche et des maladresses qui
rappelle celle d'une main étrangère je
recrée mais un mec quand même que tu vas
faire le mec pour quatre ans dans le
vaisseau spatial qui va faire le mec
comme quoi bon alors maintenant autre
histoire tu rencontres une fille le coup
de foudre énorme tu la ramènes chez toi
le premier soir ça marche aussi sublime
qu'est ce qui te gêne le plus qu'elle se
sublimer sûrement le plus moche de deux
autres sur les ondes et al rai qu'est-ce
que tu qu'est ce qu'il devienne le plus
de pas bander ou d'appeler sophie je
t'aime alors qu'elle s'appelle christie
les emmerdants fait de dire je t'aime
qu'à une pulsion à dire suis dit je
t'aime fait signer qu'elle s'affaisse
office en avant sinon quoi oui mais elle
pardonné fuyaient sur moi pour puma dans
mon surmoi contenu
tu as dit françois cette gêne pas me
répéter cinquante fois jusqu'à ce que j
imagine qu en 1989
deux cents ans après la terreur
recommence et on décide de
de tuer tous les partisans du roi tu
préfère mourir comment fusillés ou
guillotiné
je pense pas que je pense pas que je
fais une victime l'acquéreur dont je
crois pas pour vimy l'année autre alarme
yoann on imagine que tu sois mort quand
même et que tu sois réincarner tu
préfères être incarné ans christine
ockrent ou ppda le fait d abord pourquoi
pas questi nakhon autobus chaperon rouge
alors imagine qu'en 89 la terreur ne
recommence pas tout se passe bien et
juste des commémorations mais que toi
par contre on propose un dit on dit
voilà philippe léotard vous louerez
instantanément mais grâce à ça on va
trouver un vaccin pour soigner tous les
gens qui ont le sida
qu'est ce que tu vas faire mourir ou
encore janet jackson toujours le sida
j'ai rencontrés ils sont tous très
sympathiques mais ils ont plus de
risques de leur fournit aux autres et
donc je suis pas sûr que j'avais juste
réaliser les actions alors dis-moi tu
préfèrerais vivre dans un pays libre
mais très très très très très pauvres ou
dans une dictature où il ya un très très
très haut niveau dit par exemple je
préférais de pauvres dans un pays où tu
préfères être pause dans un pays libre
que non je suis quoi l'accord imagine
que tu que tu es un milliard ne me
hier deux milliards temps frais quoi
mais bolt ouais ok mais 3,9 tabak
ouais alcool ouais et qu'elle sera
encore des milliards de milliards jetés
avant je tais tu viendrais pas une
campagne électorale à ton père par
exemple il peut crever la gueule ouverte
elle rien à faire je paierai pas des
campagnes électorales à personne se
trouve c'est du gaspillage ayachi je lui
ai dit le premier but et si j'avais moi
un solo nous faire confiance
ouais je dirais que georges la mala
c'est bien moi qui vous ai vu à la
télévision aux jo est bien plus grand
acteur français très tard
[Musique]
le vrai et vous êtes l'artiste n'est ce
pas je suis comédien
aujourd'hui j'ai cessé de l'être par un
environnement à la fois je l'étais
j'étais leur à couleurs du vent d'hiver
avec l'appel elisabeth fanger c'est que
vous êtes maître dans beaucoup de choses
je ne serais pas un peu un maître
chanteur
non je suis un acteur qui change pas ça
je le sais où je vais vous écrire une
fois vous avez écrit un livre sur des
choses
forte de l'artiste la tête coupée oui
quand on est acteur on n'a pas
souvent dans chose à faire est
j'ai écrit des choses que chante écrit
un livre dont une partie est chanté à
l'olympia enfin été choqués par la
chanter ailleurs les ikhwan les
pochtrons les gens comme pas nous ouais
est ce qu'il ya un dieu prose we were ya
pas de bondoukou ya pas dire oui sinon
je serais pas là où l'on regarde pas de
dieu me dites pas que c'est triste la
vie d'artiste pas mal à vous voir non
non
y a pas de vie plus gai mais y'a pas dit
non plus
aussi plein de tristesse par demander à
sion vous devrez pas un peu un peu
dommage que au pays des à fond le
népalais sur le roi non au pays des
aveugles les borgnes sont rois voilà non
c'est mieux au pays des ivoiriens les
aveugles ont perdus au pays des mes
palais la fronde les rois ah je vous
demande et il a été lent et jean richard
white votre frère françois et ramon
purpan mais un vrai et pur et au xviiie
siècle mais elle a des cours d'école
mais non je crois pas non je tends page
sur un curé non non c'est un militant eh
ben je vous le demande lequel des 2 de
philippe lefrançois a le plus aidé
françois à être célèbre moi là je vous
parents profs de philo
quand je vois bien que vous me disiez un
petit peu ce que j'en pense à apporter à
l'humanité après un refus de tri lebel
maire de la fin oui une fois ce qu'il
m'a dit je peux vous dire la seule
phrase que m jean paul sartre c'est
philippe je mesure la force d'une idée à
la résistance qu'elle lui oppose c'est
chacun s'applique c'est un choix mais
nous savons d'où nous devons maintenant
que je vous ai sur les mains vous êtes
mon arrivée j'ai dit oui ça vous fait
quoi alors qu'on commémore la trt 89 les
ça vous fait quel effet ça me fait
gerber
je trouve un petit peu dégoûtant que
qu'on célèbre un petit peu comme ça je
me sens oui je vais vous demander ses
initiales l'apn qui attireront rpr et
d'autres qui s'opère et aveugle ce
pourrait être le parti royaliste d'après
vous non il n'ya pas de parti royaliste
et à que l'héritage d'un pouvoir
alors là je vais dans la merde c'est du
plus tard mais pour moi je jette
vraiment été à l'aise il a je vous
écoute les deux mois ouais je vous dis
adieu pour monde où ça lui aujourd'hui
ça va j'ai déjà applaudi besoin de
continuité gueulard couche-tard pinard
pétards léotard
tu crois que les gens temps reconnu dans
l'interview mystère
je crains pendant l'émission nombreux
chinois si tu penses quand on reconnaît
comme regret c'est qu'on se dit oulala
ça les chaises sont régis loisel à mon
avis
les gens se disent que t'es le robert
mitchum française oui oui sinon oui dans
l'ebit sont dits par exemple bourse en
guerre c'est chez pai est tellement
envie de chômer
alors évidemment rapport à beaucoup
d'autres acteurs je donne l'impression
que ça aux gens ouais ils ont pas vu les
autres alors gardons et j'y tiens j'ai
vu un film là de toi qui va passer à la
télévision le 1er octobre qui s'appelle
les sirènes de minuit seront des deux
c'est un très très très très grand film
pour moi qui ai plus
films moulin mais qui est grand parce
qu'il est parce qu et du rouge dedans
c'est du rouge devant parce que elle
parce que le moteur le mobilier du
racine pour moi le mobile 7 l'amour à
une mécanique implacable une fois ci
commence à y penser que le site chez
qu'angers racines du propofol loi et non
mais c'est comme une tragédie très bien
composé
et le drame du cinéma français c'est
qu'on s'attend quand on est une tragédie
à dire oui je veux dire ça y est je m'en
souviens de l'école mais là le lyrisme
millet du notation une version moderne
dans l'image
lafarge en plus tout le monde
voit tous les jours dans sa vie donc
c'est m on va dire qu'on aurait eu pour
résumer c'est pas un jour travailler
avec quelqu'un
ouais qui pour moi est un des meilleurs
mais pour - philippe lefebvre le vrai je
parle
on m'a donné une leçon et ces temps
derniers rôles d'alcoolo pareil c'est à
dire à l'eau mélangez tous des nouvelles
tijd
non j'ai trouvé un professeur qui m'a
expliqué comment il fallait faire pour
avoir jean blanc par exemple pour faire
une scène thébaux est il boit pas
non le problème n'est pas là paul émile
est drôle c'est comme si la gâcher des
côtelettes penser que le boucher est un
tueur de voeux d'ayo de vous jouer mais
vous n'avez pas quoi c'est comme si en
voyant une chaîne justement parlez vous
avez à présent qu'il avoue s'en tient
pas là dedans pourquoi parce qu'ils
jouent bien sûr ceux relatifs et bien
les alcools à manger un seul problème
c'est que je laissais fumière con ce
problème c'est que je joue mieux que les
autres
alors que l'acteur avait française on
essaye de faire l'alcool je travaillais
c'est donc cette pratique
[Musique]
mais
pourquoi je sais qu'elle est là pour
quoi répond pas il s'en fout cj que je
fais elle s'en fout
[Musique]
encore et encore
suite
[Musique]
le tous les jours depuis qu'elle est
partie pourquoi je suis tout seul mois
comme arrête de pleurnicher f
moi tu es libre tu profites en pour quoi
faire
tu attache beaucoup d'importance aux
accessoires vestimentaires certes par
exemple qu'ils étaient devenus tentait
pas trouvé ta veste jaune c'était quoi
américaine met fin à cuba fallait pas
jouer le rôle voilà du guide jouets et
jeux n'hésitez pas bonjour je cherche un
truc quoi ici que je vis de nous
et puis l'envié des normands un jour par
hasard au change de mec tu vois pas que
le chapeau ça l'acteur leur imagerie le
je suis un peu largué comme ça après ses
cadres du chapeau conseille au début
c'est philippe c'était magnifique avec
lui c'est que ya la possibilité du
chapeau je regarde le film on voit bien
qu'ils pouvaient être utilisés n'importe
comment
et moi je me fais un un seul reproche
gencives il a trois plans
il ya trois plans ou où je vais pas
l'utiliser
mais je pouvais ne pas le mettre du tout
vous pouvez le mettre tout le temps
ouais
jacky est fantastique philippe ce qui
est vous mais sur l'amour je vous
montrais et vos gardes
et ils vous donnent tous les
possibilités possible de possibilités
des nouvelles y compris celles où il ya
souvent non ça va jusque là et alors la
ppc qui l'a grand chez les blanches à
l'ignoble peroni que je n'espère janot
mais c'était le signal non ses
partenaires quand on est le meilleur 1
étoile bon si je suis très partenaires
un petit chat là je suis en train de
fermer
dir j'ai dit les partenaires fantastique
lumière formidable via des partenaires
se dire oui mais toujours attention que
j'ai fourni c'est à tes bijoux s'énerve
un journal ou un ami aux états de la
part de quelqu'un qui ont fait partie ça
fait un peu flagornerie
tu vois je m'en fous j'ai un grand film
pour mieux plaider en tant que bons fous
j'ai un grand film fut témoin la paire
superstar des couche-tard pour à l'amour
comme à la guerre chez tous les bons
disquaires voici philippe léotard qui
raconte ses hauts et ses bas l'interview
open dames quand l'acteur parle du
chanteur on écoute l'auteur un fil de
fer bonsoir vous choquer alors tu nous
fais un 33 tours qui s'appelle à l'amour
comme à la guerre ouais c'est très bien
je trouve alors parole de qui par hasard
finit plus autant j'adore vraiment
center et la musique est obligé philippe
charbon directeur musical c'est une
observation sur lui on peut le dire tu
vas nous faire un peu de saveur google
signale quand le 23 avril le 23 avril
une fourmi et la cigale et le cinéma
alors tu en connais on va continuer dans
la promo s'en étonner ou la vue qu'on
ait la table toujours lellouche
mon amie de coeur ouais de chez eux
y'a trucks qui va sortir de ce jour
s'appelle plutôt avis s'appelle le
le camion le grand ruban le grand ruban
je vais faire exemple pendant le
tournage a fait une enquête mise au pas
des chauffeurs routiers des poids lourds
et la route ils appellent ça le grand
une autoroute saison 3 nous ont jamais
le pat l'état de l'expression obstacles
et alors la scène de théâtre
alors ok novembre et je commence en
principe pour novembre
merci c'est mystérieux homme je suis ici
un contrat en quatre langues de jeu et
du spectacle en français en anglais en
espagnol en russe jusqu'en 93 et c'est
la seule hésitation c'est que c'est pas
sur sa possible d'être muni d'armes on
s'appelle un château de selles jeudi un
crs est tirée du ruisseau c'est normand
adapté mais j'ai aussi logés comme
parker c'est la pause à la police facile
les arts visuels et j'ai commencé à
trois mois est de commencer à répéter en
septembre j'ai patienté sur l écran qu
un texte en ce sens dans les jours les
postes de mur avant une page
et j'ai un enfer parce que je savais à
rationner les producteurs ce petit bain
donc j'avais fer canadien le fondu
enchaîné du déjeuner bon alors est ce
que tu es prêt j'ai de faire une
interview à l'ap et n'daw la plus grande
joie de ta carrière
le césar j'ai compris qu'ils n'étaient
pas truqués
ouais c'est bien là mais bon je viens
vague et après j'ai passé trois ans en
prison
ça fait toujours rien je perds mais
moralement la plus grande déception de
ma carrière à part les trois ans outils
rester sans travail et même chose après
une nouveau crois qu'il est juste alors
le plus grand moment de ta vie non
est-ce que c'est pas tu sais quand tu tu
restais mort un moment pendant 15
minutes
à ce jeu le plus beau qu'est ce qui
s'est passé d'un monde dit que c'est un
moment d'une volupté intense finalement
agitée témoin unique enfin c'était là
mais j'ai eu peur j'ai eu
une overdose de spirit et true la buse
et de l'aspirer non je suis pas jeune
boîte de médicaments mais l'histoire vin
c'est que j'ai eu une pareille
diaphragme et puis heureusement que
c'était une scène une cascade donc
j'avais les pompiers et oui bah oui je
suis arrivé hôpital liste risque j'avais
bien qui me prenait un autre je me
ferais attention 9 8 7
c'était bon pour le compte de quelqu'un
pour se terminer à 5 c'était beau c'est
du 50 m et ils ont été bien conservés
vous le dit pas mais quel nom lui en
diable mais reconnaît aussi je veux rire
j'en avais le plus beau moment de ta vie
maintenant
donc quand tu es mort sciemment par an
mais l'entente longer la lumière ouais
et lui alors le plus mauvais mais c'est
quand je chéris du commun pas la gueule
de tout et puis même des images et des
sons de plastique dans le nez m question
un peu plus personnelle encore plus
personnel
ce que tu préfères dans le sexe
le bout selon qu'il est bête qui est ce
qu'on voit pas ouais j'aime bien je suis
question est-ce que tu détestes la lil
bow jean les boudine rend compte que
c'est un tout la libération des outils
au contraire les gens sont méchants ceux
qui se mettaient des pompes il est cuit
au décollant d'un jeans que j'étais pike
est en carburant alors dis-moi léotard
ce que tu aimes le plus sans toi c'est
bon le thym ce mon frère moi c'est
monsieur je suis j'aime le plus chez moi
c'est la gonzesse temps côte et quand
est ce qu'ils m'apportent ouais c'est
génial on voulait dire ce que c'est
inconscient ce qu'ils décident à ma
place du gal l'instinct qui est ce que
tu aimes le moins toi le moins ce que tu
aimes le moi en toi ce que tu détestes
chez toi ma gueule qu'est ce qu'elle a
ma gueule mais les glaces gpt j'arrivais
pour de vrai ce que tu préfères dans le
métier d'acteur
c'est parmi ses us et canadien travaille
tout le temps se refroidit joue lyon
mon travail à moi c'est la vie c'est
vrai que des fois je passe tu le fais
encore tu récites et dans les bars la
nuit des poèmes de lautréamont à des
[ __ ] pour voir quand est ce qu elles
s'aperçoivent que c'est un poème et que
c'est pas toi qui lis art est
fantastique pour un acteur bien je
faisais tous les jours at il fait encore
froid mais ces deux jours ces textes se
dit tous les jours parisienne way they
were givestin est bon plus petit à petit
je vais bouger le bloc - docks loin
parce que le début et la magie que je
suis celle de pouvoir ont gelé pour
choquant il me regarde bouddhiste alors
je dire ça à des macros et à des copines
dans une ville à 10 à 7 heures du matin
en sortant il s'aperçoit au bout de
combien de temps cette thèse se montait
à la règle rien
fillon dont la cote j'avais la poésie ou
jettent occupe après je n'ai jamais
qu'il dise des [ __ ] c'est notre amour
donc ça nous travaux personne ne le dis
à personne n'a dit et ça donc j'ai
oublié ce que tu détestes dans le métier
d'acteur
les jeunes acteurs ont écrivain favori
autre option une chose pas fitzgerald ce
temps là les mois nous livre son
confrère du désert en effet pas coller
sauf dans les goussets tendre est la
nuit c'est un bel avenir mais parce que
bon on va rêver indéfiniment mais comme
ça peut faire vous avez un indéfiniment
ou alors louis 20 de l'artiste de
portraits de l'artiste au nez rouge pour
yahia nano qui devait venir la clinique
de la raison pure ouais non mais le
premier le pont viau l'artiste au nez
rouge a été retardé et diminuer
atrophiée à cause de son grand ami à moi
j'en ai dernier voir et je suis poli on
va en parler de jean bernaleau non non
non les sites et ricard
maintenant elle est venue je voulais
c'est pas simple c'est que quand était
anormal dessus tu avais écrit un
pamphlet contre solaires sur les gens et
dans l'allier qui s'appelait de quelques
précieuses ridicules de précieuses
ridicules qu'il est fondé la revue
intel quête non etiemble à céder votre
professeur wade avait mis 17 sur 20
cette note donc c'est un écrivain c'est
un écrivain détester parce que c'était
la question suivante tu t'en doutes
actuels 6e 16e jeu je pouvais trouver à
mieux et est maintenant je vois un homme
je le vois bugé partout je vais quand
vous rencontrez la cosmétique et
simplement je supporte pas il n'est pas
été plus exigeant et c'est devenu ce
piètre personnages hantés par le show
business qui est l'homme politique le
plus génial pour toi c'est que nos
frères mais va-t-on il faut attendre si
ton père à l'époque où il était ministre
de la culture au lieu de refuser de te
voir finalement s'était plus montré avec
toi est ce qu'il aurait pas eu une
meilleure image
ce que je pencherais mais parce que
c'est tout ce qui lui manque toi son
image a tout compris oui mais tu aurais
dû faire partie de la bande à léo aurait
dû faire partie de la bande à léo était
de réduire partie de la bande affirmé
l'homme politique le plus nul la liste
trop longue
vous pouvez apprendre ce qui se passe
dans ce pays en forant et personnes sur
tout le monde et tout le monde y est
sensible et plus
fois que personne ne réagit n'existe
pourtant la déception jamais gt gt en
remercier le ciel de nom en fait par
chance de venir à coeur tu es ma famille
avant lui deux grands services à la
france - les tracteurs mon corps le
temps plein dernière question le mec le
plus génial ni acteur ni hommes
politiques des acteurs et joe stejskal
believe est vivant
avec l'âge les contemporains sont âgés
plus je voudrais tu mais j'ai beaucoup
de temps j'ai maintenant à partir de
cette année chaque seconde et de gauche
comme un cadeau
vingt-cinq mille jours disait quincy
jones oui le mec le mec le plus nul de
tous il faut juste le long way toutes
catégories relever des indices et
tomberait si l'on y met plus humiliante
personnes le collet le deal est
justement c'est pas grave non mais je
sais pas de nom et avec le pull mais je
sais je le rencontre souvent c'est ça
qui me fait peur c'est que le mec le
plus là mon ami l'aider choisi qui
commence à trois jeunes
correction de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou